are we ready guys
satisfying this is the fun part
let's make it
hey what's up it's toy and I'm back with
another season of making it big the show
where Size Matters this is you versus
the guy she tells you not to worry about
this season I have a viari big surprise
for you making it big is entering the
metaverse and we filmed each episode
with a special VR camera baby look at
this
so you can literally hang out with me in
my kitchen while I surprise my friends
by making giant versions of their
favorite foods holy oh yes oh my God you
can binge the entire VR season this
December with a meadowquest 2 headset in
mega tasty whoa that was really trippy
looking at myself in VR is that how I
really look like you can also wait for
the normal 2D release dropping every
Saturday on YouTube starting this
December but I gotta tell you you've
gotta watch this in VR
make sure to subscribe and follow me for
more updates but until then I'll see you
in the tasty verse
[Applause]